Hey it's me Destin, welcome back to Smarter Every Day. So the last video I uploaded was
about helping an orphanage and trying to motivate you to help me build
this orphanage, but it's pretty clear that I messed that up.
So, I've flown over to England, I'm meeting with a friend of mine, and I'm hoping that his
personal appeal to you will get you over that hump, and help you help me.
- Hi everyone. I hope some of you have seen Destin's
video in which he was helping out those orphans in Peru, building their septic
tank, helping out with the orphanage, it's really amazing. Destin's always been a great help
to me, in fact he recently helped me gild the windows here on my
house.
[laughs]
Destin, it took him days, only a few days, and I think he did a great job, just like
he did for those people in Peru. Now you probably saw the video he put up a day or two
ago where he's asking for help, he's wanting you to help give to those people in Peru.
Just like he gave to me when he helped do up my house. A lot of people didn't
respond to Destin's original video. I guess it probably wasn't clear exactly what he
did and how awesome it was. He really wants your help, so read the video description
below, if you want to help out with a real good cause, not just gilding my windows,
but a really good cause in Peru, go and have a look at what he's done, read a bit about
it and vote, because he really needs your help, and it really is, seriously, I mean we joke around
I mean.. He didn't really gild my windows I did most of that myself but..
[laugh]
We're joking around a lot here, but seriously he's done an amazing thing, and
I think it'd be really great to help him out so, so check it out.
- So, to be more clear
this is what I need. First of all, there's something called the Project for Awesome, I need you to vote
for the Operation Leverage video for Project for Awesome.
If it gets the most votes, we get more money for the orphanage. It's important. Please vote, have your
friends vote. Second of all, please consider donating because this money is going
directly to an orphanage in Peru. It's a big deal, it's important.
I'm Destin, thank you very much. Here's some out-takes from what we did in Peru.
Have a good one. OK this is the coolest engineering
meeting I've ever had. We are here in..
We are in Peru, and we are talking about the septic system that we are
about to build for the orphanage, and we are eating monkey.
[sawing]
OK here's a perfect example of a lever in use here. We're trying to break the forms down.
[Spanish]
And no matter how hard we hit these things, we can't get them loose.
So we're putting a lot of force into it.
and it's not working, but when we use a lever, we're able to
pull them out easily. So I made fun of the
concrete bag hat, but it actually works really well.
He makes this fashionable. This is the captain. We call this Captain Morgan right?
Very good.
Alright today's fish is better than yesterday's. It's called losaya
dosaya? don saya.
Looks like some kind of shovel nosed catfish. OK so the whole
point of Not Forgotten is to try to break the cycle of abandonment. It's gonna take
all of us working on this puzzle together if we're gonna fix it. Please help.
[laughing]
[Spanish]
[music]
[ Captions by Andrew Jackson ]
captionsbyandrew.wordpress.com
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.